le présent dans le public convient
demain et après demain à l'elysée les
forces politiques ayant vocation à
constituer un groupe à l'assemblée
nationale ça vous concerne d'accord vous
irait honorer l'invitation c'est pas
pour quoi nous invite isle-aumont on est
toujours disposé à discuter on a déjà
participé à des discussions et avoir
publiquement gouverner ensemble dans ce
contexte bas il va falloir qu'il change
radicalement son programme dans ce cas
là mais si vous aviez vous y allez la
main est tendue en tout cas avant goût
de nous tendre la main pour une réunion
à l'elysée je pense qu'il serait
peut-être plus important qui clarifie
ses intentions politiques voulaient
demander de prendre je n'ai pas envie
mais après c'est et je n'ai pas envie
d'aider un président de la république
élu au mois d'avril sur un des éléments
de propositions qui me paraissait être
d'une brutalité sociale son nom obtenir
une majorité la passe pour monsieur
macron pas plus tard qu'à quelques jours
sur le tarmac avec l'avion derrière
demandé une majorité aux français
pourquoi pas laisser pourrir la vie sans
participer à un gouvernement d'union
nationale
diallo a échangé dans l'intérêt
supérieur national de la nation c'est
sympa c'est que si emmanuel macron avait
obtenu une majorité relative plus
importante où une majorité absolue hier
il aurait convié à une discussion
fait un gouvernement d'union nationale
ce que soient ses l'objet non pas pour
appliquer la politique d' emmanuel
macron tel qu'il l'a dit
un autre je sais ce que c'est possible
envie de reprendre à son compte le
programme de la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale mais ça mérite de
se dit il fait un pas vers vous est ce
que vous êtes
pardon mais vous me demandez ça
aujourd'hui sur la base d'un
sur quelles bases convoque t-il pour
discuter de quoi qu at il l'intention de
changer quand il dit ça n'a rien
d'extravagant club république parle avec
les acteurs politiques qui va lui dit
c'est moi qui vous le dis donc la
question n'allons pas faire il faut
sauver le soldat macron déjà 10 ans là
où j'allais d'abord en parler avec
d'abord on parlait pas qu'avec jean luc
mélenchon avec nos partenaires de
l'union populaire et qui vous
représentera d'ailleurs dans ce cas là
bas je ne sais pas nous allons discuter
je vous me prenez là au dépourvu si je
dis quelque chose qui est mon avis
personnel est que dans une heure
l'un d'eux nous dit quelque chose de
différent vous allez faire les gros
titres sur les désaccords indépassable
ça vous en avez vous en avait gros sur
la patate jeu en ce qui nous concerne
nous lisez chaque jeudi à moulis pas son
nom madame martichoux le diabolise pas
je vous dis simplement que tout à
l'heure jean luc mélenchon fait une
proposition une proposition et puis que
tout de suite c'est des désaccords n'ont
n'y a pas de désaccord
tweet immédiatement pour dire je ne veux
pas participer à l'ehpad non au commun
le résumé c'est que nous visitons sur la
manière la plus efficace à organiser car
comme emmanuel macron visiblement votre
première réaction à cette information
cette invitation à l'elysée c'est plutôt
toi la vie tient je vois pas quel est
l'intérêt d'une telle en accession
nationale
[Musique]